can non-convex optimization be robust
thanks for the introduction and sent to
organizers for inviting me and thanks
everyone for coming so I will be talking
about Ken non-convex optimization be
robust so this is going to be based on
joint work with you Cheung shreds in
Michael Jordan and DeeDee on you so all
of them are either here or a locally ad
Berkeley so first before talking about
robustness let's first look at why do we
care about non convex optimization so
non convex optimization is really used
everywhere in machine learning whether
you are doing something more traditional
like learning a probabilistic model or
you are doing deep learning as many
other people are doing
finding the right parameters for users a
model where the neural network usually
requires you to solve a non convex
optimization problem so there's a
difference between theory and practice
of non convex optimization in theory
traditionally people have thought that
non convex optimization on convex
optimization is np-hard in general let's
better avoid this problem and just try
to solve the problem by using some
comics relaxation but in practice that's
not what people do right in practice
people who didn't care about the fact
that non convex optimizations are empty
heart
in fact people just run very simple
algorithms like gradient descent or
stochastic gradient descent and this
algorithm actually turns out to solve
the practical problems are fairly
reasonably so why do we so why is there
a difference between theory and practice
for a non convex optimization
well of course we still don't have a
complete answer but recently many
researchers including myself we've been
trying to understand this from a
perspective of optimization landscape so
we say that non convex optimizations are
easy in practice partly because many of
the objectives that people are trying to
optimize in practice are very simple and
in this talk I will call these
objectives locally optimizable
objectives so what do I mean by that
these are
directives will have two very nice
properties so the first property is sad
for all of these objectives all the
local minima are equivalent they have
the same function value and they are all
globally optimal as you can see in this
function we have two local minima and
they are equivalent in practice this
phenomena is usually happens because of
some symmetry within the objective
function we'll see more examples later
but just for this particular function
it's clear that the function is
symmetric with respect to reflection
over the y-axis so another property that
we require for these functions is that
these functions should not have any high
order saddle points so by that I mean
every saddle point of the objective
function should look like this so this
is a very typical saddle point this is a
point which has zero gradient and has a
hessian matrix whose smallest eigen
value is strictly smaller than zero so
if I follow the negative eigen direction
the function value is going to decrease
what we don't want our cases like this
so this is a particular function with
where at this point at zero will have
zero gradient and also zero hashim so
just by looking at the first two orders
of derivatives you will not be able to
tell whether this point is a saddle
point or a local minimum but as you can
see from the picture it is not a local
minimum and these kind of saddle points
are called high order saddle points and
we assume that the objectives do not
have these high order saddle points so
under these two nice properties there
are many algorithms that are known to be
able to find a local minimum efficiently
for example our previous work showed
that gradient descent can find an
epsilon approximate local minima or
sometimes called an epsilon approximate
absolute a second order stationary point
in roughly one over epsilon squared
iterations so in addition to gradient
descent there are many other algorithms
that are known to work in this setting
and many of these algorithms can
actually improve over the number of
iterations from one or epsilon square to
something like one or absolute it's a
1.75 so so that's good we know that if
the objectives are have this very nice
property then we have very good
algorithms for finding the local and
global optimum who are these objective
functions so the remaining problem is
why are the objectives locally
optimizable right for what problems can
we say that their objects are locally
optimizable luckily throughout the years
many researchers have proved several
cases of locally optimizable functions
starting from the canonical example of
principal component analysis since this
is a classical example of a non convex
objective but does not have any bad
local optimal solution in the recent
years people were able to prove many
problems such as matrix completion or
tensor decomposition or even some
versions of neural networks have this
nice locally optimizer for objective
functions usually the guarantees in
these new works world or exists so for a
certain problem X whether is matrix
completion or a neural networks let's
say if the input data satisfies certain
assumptions in particular usually if the
input data is generated according to
some model then the objective function
is going to be local the optimizable so
that's nice in the sense that we can now
say that where all of these functions
there are objective functions are easy
and we can just use
simplest algorithms to finds a global
optimal solution for all of these
problems but on the other hand I always
worry a little bit when I see these kind
of guarantees and when I prove them
myself because we we always need to make
some assumptions because this is a non
convex optimization problem and I'm
worried about what happens if these
assumptions are are not satisfied right
what if even there are some small
perturbations to these assumptions okay
so what happens when the assumptions
fail the worry here is said when the
assumption
fail the algorithms the non convex
optimization algorithms actually will
not fail gracefully as some of them not
a convex optimization algorithms so here
I'm going to give a very simple
comparison so here this is a classical
convex optimization problem this is just
these squares problem I think of a is
vectors and bi as numbers and we are
just hoping to find parameter X which is
the least square solution or words this
set of input data AIB I write on the
other hand for non-convex optimization
let's say we still have input data
that's AI and bi but we are minimizing a
non-convex loss function l that's
related to this particular sample and
the parameter X in both cases I'm
looking to find a global optimal
solution for this unknown parameter X
okay so for comics
optimization if I think that maybe some
adversary were maybe for some reason
that I don't have the exact values of a
is and B is right maybe they are
perturbed a little bit by some adversary
or maybe I or even Archana Lee I don't
know these values with a hundred percent
accuracy right so suppose there are some
perturbations to the parameters a is and
B is may be the objective function will
change from this blue function to the
red function and of course if this
happens the global minimum is perturbed
but if as long as the change in a is and
B is are small the global minimum is
going to be still fairly close so that's
not ideal but that's ok it's a good
thing about convex optimization is this
function is convex not because I have
some particular values of a is and B is
this function is convex because it's a
quadratic function so no matter how I
perturb the AIS and V is my objective
function is still convex so whatever
algorithm that I use will still be able
to find the global minimum so what
happens for a non convex optimization
right
for non convex optimization the problem
can be much worse because when I perturb
these per hour
a ing ice said before perturbation maybe
these a is and B ice come from some
models they satisfy some nice
assumptions so my function is this nice
blue function that is locally
optimizable but after the perturbation
there's no there's nothing that prevents
a function to look like the red function
here now the problem of the red function
of course first we still observe that
the global minima are perturbed now
instead of these points we have these
green points but again that's probably
not a huge problem even if I find any
one of these green points I should be
fairly happy because they are still
fairly reasonable solutions for the
original optimization problem right but
the main problem is after this
perturbation this red function is no
longer locally optimizable because as
you can see the red function now has a
lot of local optima that are very bad
they are their function values are much
larger than the function value of the
global minimum so the function is no
longer locally optimizable and in
particular if say I run gradient descent
on this red function then it is possible
that my algorithm will get stuck here
and then I will be really unhappy
because this red point is really not a
point that I'm looking for
so in some sense and when we are working
with non convex optimization they are
more susceptible to even small
adversarial perturbations but in this
talk I'm going to show you two examples
we're under certain assumptions we can
change the algorithms and make
non-convex optimization robots question
is that what the perturbations
objective actually lovely right of
course this is just artificial example
for this function I didn't actually
write a loss function and actually try
to preserve the parameters myself what's
the what's the right model for
perturbation of these losses I think
that's the it's plausible that that
could happen it's plausible that maybe
instead what happens is you know the
left local minimum puts up a little bit
the right local minimum goes down a
little bit but kind of it's still fine
yes so that is certainly possible so in
this talk we are going to focus on this
model but this is just a one of the
examples of what you should what you
might want to do when you are working
with non convex optimization with some
perturbations if you know that the
perturbation you have come in comes from
my different models and maybe you should
design a different algorithm and for
most of the perturbation models things
are still widely open why didn't you
find the distribution model yeah like in
some senses
I mean I will show you some more
motivations when I go on into talk so so
there are reasons why we believe that we
have some function that was perturbation
might look like this I mean I'm not
claiming that all deep neural networks
are locally optimizable
I'm just saying for a very particular
version of two layer neural network for
a very particular designed function it
is optimized which is convex and great
this image can easily break the symmetry
I mean the only way a function can be
really optimizing where they start is
too much that is correct so you can
easily break it by adding a
regularization on things we can discuss
that offline it's not as easy it is easy
to break the symmetry but you still need
to up but it depends on if when you
break the symmetry your your function
might actually have different local
Optima that have had ads that have
different values how do you guarantee
that you'll find one that is good it is
not very clear I mean I can we prefer to
take that offline because that's not the
major topic of this talk okay so in the
first part of part I will talk about
what if the adversary can perturb the
function value and I will give you some
more motivation on why do we consider
the adversary to be able to perturb the
function value in what cases does this
make sense and in the second part I will
talk about some more concrete models of
the adversarial perturbations okay so in
the first setting we were trying to do
robust non convex optimization with a
perturb objective so in this setting we
have this unknown function capital F
which is the function it's a blue
function here so this function has all
the nice properties said you want
to assume let's say this capital F is
locally often when suppose it's smooth
insistence that all orders of
derivatives exist and they are bounded
local minima are very good solutions and
finding a local minima of this function
f is what I want to do okay
but unfortunately although there's this
very nice unknown function f I don't
have access to this function
I cannot compute anything on F the only
thing I have is the input which is the
small F the red function the red
function does not have these nice
properties the red function is not going
to be locally optimizable okay so where
can I draw here is smooth but we are not
even assuming that the function small F
may not even be continuous the only
thing I know is that for every point X
it's a difference between the red
function and the blue function is
bounded by some quantity new and our go
is under this assumption can we find an
epsilon approximate local minimum of the
original unperturbed function capital F
given access to this red function and
here just to be more precise by an
epsilon approximate local minimum I mean
that is a point which has norm of the
gradient is less or equal to epsilon and
the Hessian is in PSD sense larger than
minus root epsilon times identity
question
good catch now that's actually exactly
what we do but to make that work and
with the optimum parameters you need to
be a little bit more careful especially
oh yeah that's right
okay so here's another motivation for
for--why we are looking at this model so
this this motivation doesn't even have
an adverse rate perturbing things it
just happens naturally so this is a
problem with empirical risk and
population risk so remember the
definition of population risk is some
expectation of some loss function or a
input distribution and in many cases the
input distribution we can think of it as
some nice fairly smooth distribution
that's they are Gaussian and as a result
the population risk is often purely
smooth on the other hand we of course do
not have access to population risk
because that is that requires you to
take expectations and no we don't have
the infinite number of samples so in
practice what we have access to is going
to be the empirical risk which is just
the average of these loss functions over
the actual samples and this empirical
risk function may not be as smooth as
the population risk function as you can
see in this example this landscape of
this empirical risk function is very
rough it has a lot of discontinuity in
the gradient for example so in many
applications especially for neural
networks the empirical risk may not be
smooth in the sense that as gradient
does not have a Lipchitz property that's
because for neural networks the
activation function is often the random
function and the random function when
you take the derivative it jumps from 0
to 1 when you go from negative to
positive so the random function and loss
functions that's related to that usually
do not have say Lipschitz gradient
properties
but on the other hand even though the
empirical risk may not have these very
nice smooth properties we still know
that when you have large enough number
of samples the function values are still
point wise close to each other but by
some standard concentration results yes
so for new I mean this problem can be
general depending on the last functions
that you choose but for example if your
last function includes something applied
on a random function then this would
happen right if you use as most rather
that's going to and not have this
problem but depending on how much you
smooth it might have other problems I
don't think it's technically worse is
just not used in practice I guess it's
just easier to compute randoms in
practice this properties well in some
sense our solution is also suggesting
you can't just do a smoothing without
changing the objective function right so
in some sense that's that's the same
solution as using a small smooth shadow
and the point is you don't need to
compute a smooth trail you can actually
still use Redway and compute a
stochastic gradient exactly so let me
not try to go forward too quickly but
let me first state my our results so
what you can show is if the original
function capital F have all of these
nice properties then if the algorithm
had only has access to a function small
F that is point wise close to the
unknown function capital F then if this
difference nu is less or equal to
something like square root of epsilon
cube or word Rho times 1 or D here Rho
is just some literacy a mattress for the
hessian before announced
covered as a constant then there is a
polynomial time algorithm that can find
an epsilon approximate local minimum of
the original function f D is dimension
of X yeah so so this dependency might
look a bit strange right why do we have
epsilon to the power 1.5 why do we have
this extra 1 or D factor but turns out
this is in some sense right dependency
because we show a matching lower bound
we show that in the same setting if this
difference nu is larger than this bound
by a factor of log squared D again these
dimension of X any algorithm that finds
an epsilon approximate local minimum of
the original function f with at least
constant probability musk where is this
function small F where at least e to the
log square D number of times and of
course e to the log squared D is not a
polynomial in D so so any polynomial
time algorithm will not be able to do
that so our algorithm and our paper is
not the first result that considers this
setting so previously you change on
Percy Liang and Moses Cherica give a
more complicated algorithm for the
settings they use sampling techniques to
solve the same problem and not only that
their algorithm is more complicated
conceptually the dependency is also much
worse compared to our is that we
actually get a tight guarantee here ok
so as I mentioned previously the idea of
our work is actually very simple and
it's probably the first thing that you
should think about when you look at this
problem so the idea is okay we have this
red function and that has a lot of
perturbations and it's not very smooth
so maybe I'll let me just convolve this
red function with a caption in order to
get rid of these additional bad local
minima
so in order to do that what defines this
function after the Sigma of X to be the
average of f of X plus C where G comes
from a Gaussian distribution with mean
zero and variance Sigma squared in every
direction so after it is averaging
hopefully we get this green function
here which gets rid of all the bad local
minima but it still looks very similar
to the blue function so that if we
optimize the green function we are still
okay so having this definition is very
nice in the sense that for this function
of course naively are estimating the
value of this after the Sigma and every
point might require you to take a lot of
courage to the original function small F
but it turns out that we don't really
need to worry too much about that we can
actually compute a stochastic gradient
for the smooth function just by using
two queries and that's because the
gradient of this function is not very
hard to show that the gradient of this
function is just equal to one over Sigma
square times expectation over G of FX
plus C minus f of X times C so if I just
want a stochastic gradient article for
this function I just need to query the
function at two points X plus C and X
and then I will be able to compute this
factor this is not always true for India
I mean lowercase F is to be
differentiable or weakly differentiable
no the lowercase F does not have to be
differentiable the the capital F needs
to be differentiable
so you're not claiming so you are doing
the integration by parts here right so
you claim that the gradient with respect
to X of F tilde is given by that is that
formula always - you need to be F
lowercase F to be weakly differential
alright okay you're right yes
okay so yes that is right sorry on set
so so the question here is how large
does how do we choose the Sigma here and
how do we choose a right amount of
smoothing in order for this to work
well yeah you more you can but for
example you might get stuck here right
because you know even if small up here
is very smooth can be just met
measurable is fine there's no special
data it's only bounded solution will
give us the average for the point of the
gradients at me definitely
but that's nice if you don't need to be
dealing with ellipses or something no
matter I think that that expectation
might not exist for instance right
expectation might not be it's so as
small F is so first capital F is assumed
to be bounded so small F is also
abundant so if it's measurable is an
expectation definitely cancel and yeah
let's take this off basically is you're
trying to do
let's take this question off like yeah
so the main question is how large does
the Sigma needs to be and actually there
are two different effects here so if I
choose Sigma to be too small then I'm
not averaging over a large radius then
the problem is this green function might
look very similar to the red function
and then maybe it's a bad local minima
of the red function are still there on
the other hand if I choose Sigma to be
too large
maybe this green function will look
super different from this blue function
and then optimizing the green function
will tell me nothing about the blue
function itself so we need to carefully
balance between these two and the key
lemma we prove is suppose that this
function is a smooth version of f of X
then for every point we show that the
gradient and the Hessian of the smooth
function is close to the original
unknown function capital F and as you
can see both of these guarantees have
two terms I'm not going to show the
calculation but these two terms come
from the use of a triangle inequality so
basically we first bonds a difference
between capital f and a smooth version
of capital f which gives the first term
and then we also bound the difference
between those most versions of small F
and capital F and that gives the second
term as you can see if Sigma is too
large then the first term is large and
we don't have a good guarantee on the
other hand if Sigma is too small and
then the second term will be large so we
choose Sigma in order to balance between
these terms okay so as a corollary we
can just choose the Sigma carefully and
shows that every epsilon word would be
approximate local minimum of this moose
function is an absolute approximate
local minimum of capital F so that's
where the algorithm and now let me give
you some
the distance between the local minima
that's correct right does it come out
like that Sigma just looking at it looks
like Sigma the good Sigma is like
typical distance we've seen that that's
not exactly correct of the Sigma comes
from balancing these two terms but this
is a Gaussian noise very high dimension
right yes so the basic value at the
Gaussian noise is very high dimension
you're going to go to the to the
excursion D of the points you know I
mean our Sigma does have a square root D
here like the square root D here so the
total norm of the noise is actually not
that related to the dimension so anyway
let's not let me just very briefly talk
about the ideas behind the lower bounds
that be proof so the idea is actually
fairly simple so almost everything is
going to happen within this ball so
within this fall we will just pick a
random Direction V and we will not of
course the algorithm will not know this
random Direction V so we will construct
a function capital F such that capital F
only have two local minima within the
spot and both of them are in direction
of V or I guess one is in the direction
of V one is in the direction of minus V
and what we will do is to construct this
function in a way such that it is very
flat in this band in the middle so the
width of this band we are we are
actually going to set it to log square
the over square root if the radius of
the ball is going to be one so we will
make sure that the capital F is fairly
flat in this region so that when we
perturb the function we can make sure
that small F is exactly a constant over
this band so when ever the algorithm
courage anything within this band
it just receives a constant and the
constant does not give any information
about this vector V so in order to know
anything about the vector V and actually
find one of these two
minimum then the algorithm must hum how
be able to curry a point that is not
within this band but we all know that
this is a high dimensional setting and
if the width of the band is log squared
D over square root D then the volume of
this blue region is actually very very
small so it no matter how the algorithm
is curving it needs to make a lot of
courage until it hits one of the blue
points and before doing that it will
have no information about what is what
this direction B is and of course we
need to carefully construct these
function and we need to talk about what
happens out outside of the spot but
those can all be handled okay let's go
to the next example so in the next
example I will show you a result about
matrix completion again semi random
adversary' so matrix completion is a
very familiar problem maybe to most of
people but let me still introduce it
very briefly here
we have any experts for matrix condition
here so there's a underlying low rank
matrix and that we do not know the only
thing we know are some entries of M and
our goal is based on these observations
of M we want to recover the remaining
entries usually this is applied to
recommendation systems because we think
of this as a matrix between users and
items and IJ's entry is just user is
reading to item J so the reason we think
that this matrix might be low rank is
because we can think about it writing it
as a product of two low rank of factors
and in this sense every row here
correspond to an R dimensional feature
for the user every column here
correspond to an R dimensional feature
of the item and the rating is just the
inner product of these R dimensional
features the benefit of this is of
course on the right hand side there are
at most two times n times R parameters
so we can hope to recover all the
parameters using roughly n times R
observations times log factor asyou yeah
so in practice you actually need to
multiplied by log so how do you solve
this problem the most naive approach is
probably just to write a non convex
optimization objective the objective is
very simple I'm trying to look for
factors and x and y-axes just the first
low ranked factor y is the second low
rank factor I want a product XY
transpose IJ to agree with my
observations whenever I have observed a
entry right so that's the objective
previously we were able to prove that
matrix completion has this locally
optimizable property in the sense that
when the number of observations is large
and if the observed entries are chosen
uniformly at random then all of local
minima are global there are of course a
lot of prior works here there are many
works on convex relaxation or non convex
optimization with carefully chosen
starting point and all of these works
actually get better dependency on R but
that's not the main topic of our talk
here the main things that I want to talk
about is a question about what happens
if the observed in traits do not satisfy
this assumption that they are chosen
uniformly at random right because if you
think about it the assumptions that also
observed in trees are uniformly at
random is not really reasonable it says
for every user I and every item J the
probability that user ID reads item J is
exactly the same and that's unlikely
because it user ID rated item J then the
same user is more likely to usually read
some related items for example so there
are certainly possibly some correlations
between how are the observed increase
chosen right what is your major is
sports what if you are original matrix
is sparse right right so so here I'm
hiding some details so in all of these
matrix inclusion works including ours
there is an assumption called
incoherence and any matrix that
satisfying coherence cannot be very
sparse
okay so what we worry about here is what
if the observed entries are not
uniformly random and in particular we
consider a semi random anniversary so in
this model we assume the input data or
the observed entries are generated in a
two-step procedure so at the beginning
we think of the instance we'll start
with uniformly random observations so
think of this as a baseline a
probability so for every user I and
every item J there's at least a lower
bound on the probability P that the user
will gives the rating right so this is
how we get these ratings but after that
an adversary can come and the
anniversary can choose to review more
entries so the adversary is actually
fairly limited it cannot review an entry
that's incorrect so whatever interests
that the adversary review is also
correct it cannot change any entry sets
previously reviewed it cannot delete any
entries so it seems like the adversary
is fairly weak right intuitively the
adversary is only giving the algorithm
more information because I now observe
more samples so why it is to adversary
doing that right in some sense this is
correct because for all the convex
relaxation algorithms it's very easy to
show when you have more observations if
you were able to recover the low rank
matrix before you will still be able to
recover the same matrix but
unfortunately if you use a non convex
optimization algorithm and if you are
observation comes from a semi random
adversary then we show that the
objective function that we just saw can
have a bad local minimum and this is not
just having a bad local minima I
mentioned that your algorithms that have
very clever initialization algorithms
even if you use those initialization
algorithms the optimization can still
get stuck in these bad local optimal
solutions so that's a problem but we
also show that there is an efficient
pre-processing step that runs in
polynomial in the rank
times the number of
after increase in this amount of steps
at this pre-processing step will produce
a new objective function and this new
objective function will not have any bad
local minima okay so let's get some
intuitions on how these how we can prove
these let's first look at a counter
example to understand what can go wrong
with these semi random adversary's so
here's an example where the objective
actually have a bad local optimum so the
underlying matrix is very simple it's
all ones matrix right so of course the
solution should be access to all one
spectra so now the adversary is going to
choose to review more entries in these
two diagonals locks okay so in by doing
that it actually turns out that this X
with once on this block and minus ones
on this block is going to be a local
optimal solution and of course this is
not coppola optimal because as you can
see the off diagonals locks are
incorrect so the reason that this
becomes this suddenly becomes a local
optima is because this bad solution
actually is not discovering the
structure of the underlying matrix it
discovered it's a structure of the
observation positions because if I think
of the observed positions it forms a
block diagonal matrix and this vector is
just a icon vector of that block
diagonal matrix so how do we deal with
this problem
well if we knew the adversary is
changing the probabilities in this way
where is revealing additional entries in
this way we can try to rebate the
interest to say okay interest in these
diagonals locks are not so important the
interest in these off diagonal blocks
are more important so when we try to
reread the samples so that the input is
actually in some sense similar to a
random input so more formally how do we
do that well in the objective function
will just add a weight W IJ in front of
each observations hydrant and we know a
good set of weights exist because if I
just set W IJ to be one for entry sets
reviewed by an
in the first step and wi j to be zero
for anything added by adversary this
function will be the same as before and
it will have the nice properties but of
course I can't do this because I don't
know which entries are added by an
adversary so what do I do
right so to think about this problem we
actually reformulate the problem as a
graph problem so we think of this matrix
this observation entries as a bipartite
graph between rows and columns so here
the first row have three observed
interests that correspond to three edges
in the graph similarly these are the
artists or edges in the graph so the
previous problem now becomes a graph
problem where we start with an artist in
a bipartite graph and the adversary will
add some more edges our goal is to
recover the original edges that's that
were into our dish and the part of the
graph but this is in general not
possible because the adversary can just
try to add another artist in the graph
on top right so instead of actually
recovering G we only need two rebates a
new graph so that H is actually similar
to G in the sense that the LOB Russians
have very similar spectral properties
I'm not running out of time so I'm not
going to give any details we give an
algorithm that I can actually solve this
graph problem in times as many times
probably one or absolute where m is the
number of edges our technique is based
on these algorithmic techniques
developed for draft specification which
given a dense graph can produce a sparse
graph with the same spectral property so
there's a long line of work here since
the seminal work of Spearman that come
okay so just to sum up I showed that non
convex optimization are in general more
susceptible to address or perturbations
because even findings are global Optima
requires assumptions when the
perturbation is small in magnitude we
show that smoothing can removes a bad
local minima introduced by perturbation
in some other cases for semi random
adversary' we can choose to modify the
objective function in order to protect
the algorithm
so there are many open problems and
these are just two very preliminary
examples so there are many other models
of corruption for example the Hooper
model of corruptions that's mentioned
many times in this workshop can we
handle that kind of model when we have a
non convex optimization problem right we
also want more efficient algorithms
algorithms that I talked about are in
polynomial time but they are not as fast
as their non robust counterparts so can
we have algorithms that have similar
performance or at least are very
practical in practice Thanks smoothing
introduced poly defects in the run time
so can we not use these methods to do
deep learning that avoids look bad local
minima or is it is it not there yet I
think it's not there yet
you're semi-random model for [ __ ]
confusion haunted the local job I mean
the local geometry around the globe oh
man oh it's a good question so the local
geometry actually does not change so
much as far as I know but I don't know
what is the radius of contraction now
because previously it's possible to show
a radius of contractions that's fairly
large now very locally nothing is
changing but I don't know what happens
to the radius of contraction and you
show how the number of entrances change
by the adversary oh there's no upper
bound on the number of interests that
are revealed by the adversary so
adversary can review as many entry said
as it wants and algorithm was to be able
to work
there's the algorithm in the first part
of the top work for the semi random if
you don't do the really oh no so the
algorithm in the first part will not
work for the semi random model is
especially because the number of
adversarial edges is not even bounded by
the number of good edges third thing
which is just to set the W so that so
since that's a good question but if you
look at this counter example here
actually already in this every row and
column have roughly the same number of
nonzero entries so this counter example
is also a counter example to the degree
normalized version it's like no here is
this probability P should be at least
some log of poly log and what if the
matrix is and by ends is the base
probabilities the lower bound on the
probability P should be at least poly
log and over N the probability for these
denser diagnol blocks only needs to be a
constant factor larger than the base
probability so the amount of adverse or
edges added is roughly proportional to
the number of original edges action
absolutely the first part of the talk is
their benefit in like reducing the Sigma
as I'm going closer to the right so the
question is does it make sense to maybe
start with a large smoothing radius and
gradually reduce it as the algorithm
goes on I guess in the worst case it
probably doesn't help because we do show
a lower bound but maybe there are cases
where this actually because this makes a
lot of sense so maybe there are cases
when this actually works okay thanks
[Applause]